a now Infamous sentence in my play group
is wow this opening hand would be great
if it had more lands whenever it's said
either me or my friend Mr Hans will sit
up straight get a devious glint on our
eye and say yeah nine card hands are
pretty good this is a joke that will
never stop finding funny but the
frequency with which people Express the
original sentiment also speaks to a
broader point about lands despite their
centrality to the game a lot of people
don't really see lands as a part of
their deck in any meaningful sense if
your hand was missing something else you
find vital to your game plan an artifact
a creature a piece of ramp you wouldn't
say wow this opening hand would be great
if it had an artifact in it because
that's a silly statement to make an
opening hand without an artifact in it
in an artifact deck is a bad hand not a
mildly flawed good hand to take this a
step further I think a lot of people
have a mindset of Ls being a sort of
necessary evil a card type that dilutes
the gas of a deck and one that should be
played in the lowest quantity that a
player can get away with
I don't necessarily want to invalidate
the desire to draw gas but I do think
that what I just described is a mindset
that will naturally lead to deck
building mistakes so to start with I
want to lay out a basic framework for
the approximate number of lands that you
should be running in your deck I've seen
a lot of numbers paraded around by
various people as general reference
points and to be frank I think a single
number does a poor job of answering the
question speaking of Frank let's start
there Frank carsten has done an
admirable job of answering questions of
Mana and Mana fixing and his analysis on
the subject of land count is as good a
place to start as any for the topic the
format agnostic version of Carson's land
count analysis goes something like this
he takes a whole bunch of match data
from across a couple years of online MTG
events and excludes any deck that didn't
have more wins than losses he then does
a regression analysis on the remaining
decks which sounds complicated but is
actually pretty simple in concept A
regression analysis basically just cares
about how a bunch of predictor variables
correlate with an out output variable in
this case the question Carston's
analysis is asking is how do manac curve
quantity of cheap draw spells and
quantity of cheap Ram spells affect how
many lands a successful deck plays the
result of this question is then turned
into a formula that can be used to
determine the number of lands that a
given deck should play and as a starting
point I like this I'd argue that average
Mana value as well as quantities of
cheap draw ramp should be major factors
used to decide land count in a deck and
I've left a link to that article in the
description if you want to give
Carston's formula a try however since it
was constructed from 60c card deck data
Carston's analysis here misses out on
some specific factors involved in EDH
and he himself is aware of this another
article of his lays out a different set
of criteria for Mana curve ramp and land
count in an EDH specific context due to
the absence of good data on EDH games
this article obtains its findings
through simulated games against a
passive opponent with the model
optimizing for for the highest quality
curve out this quality is defined here
as a single number being composed of the
Mana value of each card played repeated
on each turn thereafter to simulate the
value of having played a spell that
influences the game the model factors in
a number of Commander specific
assumptions such as the free Mulligan
and the commander being effectively an
extra non-land card available at all
times and honestly I like this model A
Lot not because it's perfect but because
it's simple and specific it gives land
count ramp count and Mana curve
recommendations based purely on the goal
of curving out cards aren't necr poent
and Rewind and aquaa they're
hypothetical pieces of cardboard with
Mana value three four and two
respectively and to assume that they're
different from each other Beyond this
information would introduce an
unreasonable level of complexity to the
model so as with the land count formula
it's a good starting point it offers
some neat recommendations on optimal
land counts Mana rock counts and Mana
curve and comes to the conclusion that
for purposes of curving out properly
decks would be well served to run at
least 37 lands and as many as 42 in some
cases this is good information but the
Simplicity and specificity of the model
mean that to get the full picture we
need to venture a bit beyond its scope
Carston's assumptions themselves offer a
neat place to start thinking and I'm
most interested in his assumption about
the commander his model assumes it to be
effectively a non-land card like any
other but one you have available all the
time this is a decent shortcut for
purposes of putting together a model but
the commander of a deck can have a
wildly important impact on the curve and
desired land count of the deck Beyond
just occupying a Mana slot specifically
there are commanders that offer some
form of draw or filtering and these will
influence the number of lands a deck is
looking to run if you're building a Rona
Deck with lots of one and two cost
legendaries as long as you run enough
blue sources to guarantee playing Rona
on turn two your black sources and land
count as a whole can be a bit lower
since you know you're going to turn
through a lot of cards on turns three
and four similarly a Yar deck can go a
bit heavier on ramp and a bit lighter on
lands knowing that as long as it's able
to get up to Yar it'll have its next
couple land drops for free these
examples make sense as there cases when
a player will have guaranteed access to
a high quality tool for drawing into
additional lands however I also want to
talk about a different type of Commander
that I think will be more controversial
that being the high- costed Commander
that draws a lot of cards if your
commander costs four or more and draws
cards not only should you not run less
lands than you otherwise would you
actually should run more that's a draw
spell you'll have every single game and
your only barrier between yourself and
those sweet sweet cards is drawing
enough lands or ramp to get there ditto
if the deck is very heavy on draw that
costs a lot of Mana medium to large draw
will cut through that slightly higher
density of lands with no problem so
running a higher land count won't hurt
you it will only serve to lessen the
chance of screw and I'll go a step
further here I suspect the reason a lot
of people end up running low land counts
isn't because they've done a lot of
field testing and decided that they need
to be drawing more gas it's because they
get finished adding cards to the deck
and feel attached to the non-land stuff
they put in making Cuts can be a
somewhat painful and difficult process
so if EDH fan99 tells you that you can
run 33 lands a lot of people will take
that advice very eagerly and then down
the road they'll curse the luck Gods
when they get stuck on four lands in
their deck whose average Mana value is
4.5 and I say this with a heart full of
empathy I've been there but sometimes
you just got to bite the bullet and make
those cuts another factor that influence
land count is colors both the number of
colors and the symbol density well kind
of see this is a subject that's a bit
harder to solve with big brained deck
building tips the annoying truth is if
you want to run a lot of colors and you
don't want to run a whole lot of tap
plans in order to to actually get the
colors you need you either need to spend
hundreds of dollars on a Mana base full
of fetches and shocks or you need to run
a lot of lands and I do not say this
from sitting on top my Throne of
paper-made copies of brisk study I don't
run many fetches and shocks in my decks
due to their cost and I honestly find
the effectiveness of them to be a little
upsetting if you're willing to spend
money you can run a lot of colors with
basically no downside and if you aren't
willing to spend money you can't do that
but I'm not here to get upset I'm here
to give you actionable advice and that
advice is if you can justify buying
fetches in shocks or if you feel like
proxying you should run them if you're
like me and you can't justify that
purchase you should either play fewer
colors or run more
lands as an example of this principle I
built out four manabases for a
hypothetical four-color Deck with blue
and green being dominant colors the
first one was 30 lands $300 and a 10%
tap lands allowance a decidedly solid
Mana base if you're okay with the low
overall count symbols wise it's 22 each
for green and blue and 16 each for red
and black pretty good numbers for coming
from just 30 lands not even including
any sort of ramp the second one was 30
lands again but $50 this time and a 1/3
tap land allowance the symbols for this
deck are 20 each for green and blue and
13 each for red and black definitely
worse but not horrendously so as long as
you're okay with tap lands a well-built
ramp Suite should be able to patch up
those numbers to something that ends up
being pretty reliable
the third one was 30 lands and $50 once
again but going back to the 10% tap land
allowance this is where things get
painful 16 symbols each for green and
blue and 10 each for red and black this
is rough our core colors aren't even
well supported and 10 is a low enough
count for our off colors that we'll
quite frequently be missing one or both
of them however if we dial the land
count up to 40 with equivalent per card
budget our count jumps back up to 20 for
the core colors and 13 for the off
colors the same as the more tap land
oriented 30 land option I should
reiterate that this still isn't amazing
but it's a good demonstration of the
trade-offs involved with building a Mana
base I could go into specific cycles of
lands and when they should or shouldn't
be used but this video is long enough
already so I won't instead I want to
talk more about the Mana symbols and how
to know how many of each you'll need
this is another area where lots of
people have posited various counts and
formulas and such like and to start with
I'm going to stick with a familiar face
Frank carsten also posted an article
offering an analysis of the number of
each symbol deck should run in order to
be able to consistently play a card when
they have enough total Mana with
consistently being 89 plus m% of the
time where m is the Mana value of the
card one application of this formula and
resulting table would be to apply it to
every single card in your deck and then
build a Mana base that gets as close as
possible to satisfying this for every
single card this Works in Faster formats
where most or all cards want to be
played on curve but it works a bit less
well at
EDH I do think it's appropriate to apply
this strict 89 plus m% standard for
pivotal cards you want to land on curve
such as a commander or ramp spell
however for stuff you need a little
later such as High Drops combo pieces or
removal you can put them behind a
substantially lower symbol count as long
as you've got enough draw and ramp to
help you get the needed symbols by the
time you need those cards this doesn't
necessarily mean you should totally let
your guard down on that sort of stuff
though certainly if you're running a lot
of colors or if you're running symbol
heavy cards it's worth taking a careful
look at your manabase to make sure
things will work out I recommend
checking out the chart in Frank Carson's
article which I Linked In the
description but as a bit of Shand 30
symbols in your Mana base will give you
great access to all but the most symol
intensive cards 25 symbols will give you
great access to single symbol cards and
decent access to double symbol cards 20
will give you decent access to single
symbol cards and mediocre access to more
symbols and 15 symbols will give you
okay access to single symbol cards but
will be unreliable beyond that for an
example of one of my Mana bases My Maria
deck runs 37 lands with 23 red symbols
and 22 Green symbols the deck is pretty
low curved and has a three man Commander
that ramps so the lands and symbols are
mostly to make sure that I can drop the
commander on curve consistently when I
run the deck through Frank Carson's land
count formula it's right on the money
which makes sense to me since the
commander ramps which would make me okay
with fewer lands but also draws which
would make me fine with more for my
gissa deck I'm running 41 total lands
with 31 green sources and 22 black
sources this count might sound high but
it's totally justifiable it's a high
curved deck it has card draw in the
command Zone and its ideal Mana curve is
Elf on one commander on two having Mana
issues in my first three turns will
dramatically slow down the deck as it
won't be able to get its draw and ramp
online so I'm pretty comfortable with a
high land count in fact fact Carson's
formula generates an even higher count
of 43 and some change which might
partially be because the deck's average
Mana value of 4.71 would likely be an
outlier in Carson's data set but there
are legitimate Arguments for adding
lands to the deck regardless a general
pattern across my decks is that even
when they're relatively low curved I
still generally run a high 30s quantity
of lands in them as long as they can
draw a lot of cards Mana screw is
optional and if you run a deck with big
draw running more lands is your way of
unticking that
box I've covered a lot of stuff in this
video and I've meandered a little bit so
let me clarify what I'm actually trying
to say here for one you should be
intentional with the number of lands you
run and keep in mind that the optimal
number might be higher than the sorts of
numbers that get thrown around on the
internet Frank Carson's formula for the
ideal count is a good start though since
it wasn't designed with EDH in mind it
may be correct to deviate from it in
some cases you can run fewer lands if
your commander provides a consistent way
to draw into additional lands in the
early game but you should always check
your symbol count to make sure you have
enough to play important cards when you
need to and you should keep in mind that
if you're running a deck that runs a lot
of big expensive draw keeping your land
count high will almost certainly make
the deck stronger a land base will
naturally perform two functions
achieving total Mana values of cards and
achieving colored symbols for cards and
neither goal can be ignored these goals
can be modulated to some extent by
running certain types of lands running
tap PLS that offer more colors can be
good in a deck that is color hungry but
doesn't need as much speed and colorless
producing util lands can be nice for a
deck that wants a higher land count but
already feels comfortable color-wise I
didn't talk much about tap lands and
utility lands in general because the
script was already looking a little
thick but I'll get back to those at some
point regardless just pay attention to
your Mana base if you still can't fully
think of it as part of your deck you
should at least think of it as your
little helper if you show your Mana base
the love and appreciation you show your
nonland cards it'll pay you back by
helping you actually do the things your
deck wants to
do fun update I have a Discord Now link
in the pinned comment so go join that if
you feel like though first you should
click the buttons subscribe like dislike
and the other ones too preferably you
should click all of them in Rapid
succession I hear if you click them just
right they give you some sort of prize
good luck